Je suis censé vous effrayer parce que c'est à propos de la peur, non?
Et vous devriez avoir peur,
mais pas pour les raisons auxquelles vous pensez.
Vous devriez avoir peur que
si on peut avoir le premier slide -- voilà -- que vous loupiez quelque chose.
Parce que si vous avez passé votre semaine à penser à l'Irak et
à penser à propos de Bush et à penser au marché boursier,
vous allez manquer l'une des plus fabuleuses aventures qu'on ait jamais pu vivre.
Et voilà ce dont il s'agit.
C'est de l'ADN cristallisé.
Chaque être vivant sur cette planète, tous les insectes, les bactéries, les plantes,
les animaux, les être humains, les politiciens ( rires )
sont codés avec ça.
Et si vous prenez un seul cristal d'ADN, ça ressemble à ça.
Et on commence tout juste à comprendre ce que c'est.
Et c'est la plus excitante des aventures qu'on ait jamais vécue.
C'est le plus formidable projet qu'on ait jamais pu vivre.
Si vous pensez que la découverte des États-Unis a changé quelque chose,
ou atterrir sur la Lune ou encore ça,
c'est notre propre carte et la carte de chaque plante,
chaque insecte et chaque bactérie qui change réellement les choses.
Et ça commence à nous en dire long sur l'évolution.
( rires )
Il se trouve que c'est -
Richard Dawkins en a déjà parlé -
une véritable rivière sortie de l'Eden.
Les 3.2 milliards de paires de bases qui se trouvent à l'intérieur de vos cellules
est une histoire d'où vous avez été ces derniers milliards d'années.
Et on pourrait commencer à dater certaines choses,
on pourrait commencer à changer la médecine et l'archéologie.
Si vous prenez l'espèce humaine il y a environ 700 ans, il s'avère que
les Européens se sont distingués des Africains de manière très nette.
Les Européens ont été confrontés à la peste.
Et face à la peste, la plupart des gens n'ont pas survécu,
mais ceux qui ont survécu avaient une mutation du récepteur CCR5.
Cette mutation a été transmise à leur enfants
étant donné qu'ils étaient les survivants,
la population a donc été confrontée à une forte sélection.
En Afrique, étant donné qu'il n'y avait pas de telles villes,
il n'y a pas eu de sélection pour la mutation CCR5.
On peut dire que ça date de 700 ans.
C'est une des raisons pour lesquelles le SIDA frappe aussi fort en Afrique
et non en Europe.
Et nous sommes en train de trouver ces détails pour la malaria,
pour les cellules falciformes, pour les cancers.
Le fait de dessiner notre propre carte,
est la plus formidable aventure qu'il nous soit donné de vivre.
Et vendredi, je veux que vous sortiez une très bonne bouteille de vin,
et je veux que vous leviez votre verre à ces deux personnes.
Parce que ce vendredi, 50 ans plus tôt, Watson et Crick découvraient la structure de l'ADN
et c'est un date presque aussi importante
que le 12 février, date à laquelle nous avons dessiné notre carte pour la première fois.
Mais bref, continuons.
Je croyais qu'on allait parler du nouveau zoo.
Vous avez tous entendu parler d'ADN, de tout ce que l'ADN fait,
mais les découvertes que l'on est en train de faire sont assez élégantes
parce que ça s'avère être l'espèce la plus abondante sur la planète.
Si vous pensez être bien adapté ou que les blattes le sont,
il se trouve qu'il y a cents millions de milliards de milliards de Pleurococcus dehors.
Et on ne savait pas que Pleurococcus était là.
C'est une des raisons pour laquelle
ce projet de cartographie est si important.
Parce qu'on commence à apprendre
d'où nous venons et ce que nous sommes.
Et on trouve des amibes comme celle-ci. C'est Amoeba dubia.
Et Amoeba dubia ne nous ressemble pas beaucoup,
si ce n'est que chacun d'entre vous a environ 3.2 milliards de lettres
qui font que vous êtes ce que vous êtes
tout comme le code dans chacune de vos cellules.
Cette petite amibe
qui se trouve dans l'eau par millions de milliards
se révèle contenir un code génétique de 620 milliards de paires de base.
Donc ce petit machin a un génome
qui fait 200 fois la taille du vôtre.
Et si vous pensez à l'efficacité du mécanisme de stockage de l'information,
on se trouve assez loin des puces électronique.
On se trouve plutôt proche de quelque chose qui ressemble à cette amibe.
Et, une fois de plus, on découvre la vie et comment elle fonctionne.
Cette petite chose, les gens n'imaginaient même pas
que ça valait la peine de prélever des échantillons dans les réacteurs nucléaires
parce que c'était dangereux et, bien sûr, parce que rien ne vivait là-dedans.
Et finalement quelqu'un a pris un microscope
et a observé l'eau qui se trouvait à côté du cœur des réacteurs.
Et dans cette eau à côté du cœur des réacteurs
se trouvait Deinococcus radiodurans qui nageait le crawl,
qui se faisait détruire ses chromosomes chaque jour six, sept fois,
qui les recollait,
qui vivait au milieu de radiations qui vous tueraient 200 fois.
Et maintenant vous devriez avoir un idée du point auquel
la vie peut être diversifiée, importante et intéressante,
et du nombre de différentes formes de vie qu'il peut y avoir,
et du fait qu'il puisse y avoir différentes formes de vie
vivant à des endroits très différents, peut-être en dehors de cette planète.
Parce que si vous vivez au milieu de telles radiations,
ça amène des questions intéressantes.
Ce petit machin, on ne savait pas que ce machin existait.
On aurait dû savoir que ça existait
parce que c'est la seule bactérie que vous pouvez voir à l'œil nu.
Cette chose fait 0.75 millimètres.
Elle vit dans une fosse de la côte de Namibie.
Et cette Namibiensis que vous voyez
est la plus grande bactérie qu'on ait jamais vue.
Elle fait à peu près la taille d'une petite virgule dans une phrase.
Pareil, on ne savait pas que ça existait il y a trois ans.
On commence à peine ce voyage de la vie dans le nouveau zoo.
En voilà une vraiment particulière. C'est Ferroplasma.
La raison pour laquelle Ferroplasma est intéressante est qu'elle mange du fer,
elle vit dans l'équivalent de l'acide d'une batterie
et produit de l'acide sulfurique.
Quand vous pensez à des formes de vie particulières,
quand vous pensez à ce que ça demande de vivre,
il s'avère que c'est une forme de vie vraiment efficace.
Et ils l'appellent une archea. "Archea" signifie "les anciens".
Et la raison pour laquelle elles sont anciennes est que cette chose
est apparue lorsque cette planète était couverte
par de l'acide de batterie
et elle mangeait du fer quand la terre faisait partie d'un noyau liquide.
Donc ce ne sont pas seulement aux chiens, aux chats, aux baleines et aux dauphins
que vous vous devriez penser et auxquels vous devriez vous intéresser au cours de ce périple.
Votre crainte devrait être le fait que vous n'êtes rien,
que vous ne vous intéressez qu'à des choses qui sont temporaires.
George Bush... il va s'en aller, vous savez? Pas la vie.
Que les humains survivent ou non,
ces choses vont vivre sur cette planète ou d'autres planètes.
Et on ne fait que commencer à comprendre ce code qu'est l'ADN.
C'est véritablement l'aventure intellectuelle la plus intéressante
qui nous ait jamais été offerte.
Et vous pouvez faire des choses bizarres avec ça. Voici un brochet crocodile.
Des groupes de protection animalière
essaient de trouver comment reproduire une espèce quasiment éteinte.
Ils n'y arrivent pas naturellement, alors ils prennent une cuiller,
ils prélèvent quelques cellules de la bouche d'un brochet crocodile adulte, codent,
prennent ces cellules et les insèrent dans un ovule de vache fertilisé,
ils reprogramment. Fœtus de vache, code génétique différent.
Quand vous faites ça, la vache donne naissance à un brochet.
On fait maintenant des expériences avec des bongos, des pandas, des elos*, des tigres de Sumatra
et les Australiens, loués soient-ils,
jouent avec ça.
Le dernier est mort en septembre 1936.
Ce sont des tigres de Tasmanie. Le dernier recensé est mort au zoo Hobart.
Mais alors qu'on en apprend de plus en plus sur le code génétique
et sur la manière de reprogrammer les espèces,
on pourrait bien combler les trous d'ADN détériorés.
Et quand on sait comment combler ces trous génétiques,
on peut obtenir un brin d'ADN entier.
Et si l'on fait ça, si on insère ce brin dans un ovule de loup fertilisé,
on peut donner naissance à un animal
qui n'a pas mis les pieds sur Terre depuis 1936.
Vous pouvez ensuite remonter plus loin dans le passé,
vous pouvez penser aux dodos,
et à d'autres espèces.
À d'autres endroits, comme dans le Maryland,
ils essaient de découvrir qui est notre ancêtre commun.
Étant donné que chacun d'entre nous contient notre code génétique entier,
où nous avons été au cours des derniers milliards d'années,
comme nous avons tous évolué à partir de ça,
vous pouvez retourner cet arbre de la vie.
Et comme nous apprenons à reprogrammer,
nous allons peut-être donner naissance à quelque chose
très proche de l'être primordial.
Et tout ça sort de choses qui ressemblent à ça.
Ce sont des compagnies qui n'existaient même pas il y a 5 ans.
Des énormes sites de séquence génétique qui font la taille de terrains de football.
Certains sont publiques. D'autres sont privés.
Il a fallu environ 5 milliards de dollars pour la première séquence d'un être humain.
Environ 3 millions la deuxième fois.
On aura un génome pour 1000 dollars dans 5 à 8 ans.
Chacun d'entre vous aura donc son code génétique entier sur un CD.
Et ça sera vraiment ennuyant, ça ressemblera à ça.
( rires )
Ce qui est beau, c'est que c'est la vie.
Laurie va en parler un petit peu.
Parce que si vous trouvez ça dans votre corps,
vous êtes mal en point car c'est le code d'Ebola.
Une des maladies connues de l'Homme les plus mortelles.
Mais les plantes et les insectes fonctionnent de la même manière
et cette pomme fonctionne de la même manière.
Cette pomme est la même chose que cette disquette.
Car cette chose code en 1 et 0,
et celle-là code en A, T, C, G et reste là-haut
à absorber de l'énergie sur un arbre jusqu'à un beau jour
où elle a assez d'énergie pour taper "Enter" et s'en aller d'un coup. Pas vrai?
( rires )
Et lorsqu’elle ouvre son fichier .exe,
elle compile la première ligne de code qui se lit :
AATCAGGGACCC, ce qui signifie "créer un racine".
Ligne de code suivante : "créer un tige".
Ligne de code suivante, TACGGGG : "produire une fleur blanche,
qui éclot au printemps, qui sent ça".
Tant que vous avez le code
et tant que vous pouvez le lire...
la première plante a d'ailleurs été lue il y a deux ans,
le premier humain a été lu il y a deux ans,
le premier insecte a été lu il y a deux ans,
la première chose qu'on ait lue, a été lue en 1995,
un petite bactérie nommée Haemophilus influenza.
Tant que vous avez le code, comme vous le savez tous,
vous pouvez le modifier et vous pouvez reprogrammer des formes de vie
pour faire un vaccin à partir de ce machin
ou pour que ce machin se mette à produire des biomatériaux.
C'est pourquoi DuPont produit un type de polyester
qui a la consistance de la soie.
ça change toutes les règles. C'est la vie, mais nous sommes en train de la reprogrammer.
Voilà à quoi vous ressemblez. C'est l'un de vos chromosomes.
Et ce que vous pouvez faire,
c'est déterminer précisément quel est ce chromosome,
quel est le code génétique de ce chromosome à cet endroit,
ce que codent ces gènes, contre quels animaux ils codent
et vous pouvez ensuite relier tout ça à la littérature scientifique.
Étant donné que vous êtes capables de faire ça, vous pouvez rentrer à la maison,
aller sur Internet, et accéder
à la plus grande bibliothèque du monde, une bibliothèque de la vie.
Et vous pouvez faire des choses assez étranges.
Tout comme il est possible de reprogrammer cette pomme,
Cliff Tabin de l'École de Médecine de Harvard
reprogramme des embryons de poulet pour qu'ils aient plus d'ailes.
Pour quelle raison Cliff ferait-il ça? Il ne possède pas de restaurant.
( rires )
La raison pour laquelle il reprogramme cet animal de façon à avoir plus d'ailes
est que quand vous vous amusiez avec des lézards étant enfant,
leur queue repoussait après être tombée.
Ce n'est pas le cas chez les humains.
Vous coupez un bras ou une jambe, ça ne repousse pas.
Mais comme chacune de vos cellules contient votre code génétique entier,
chacune d'elle peut être reprogrammée - si l'on n'arrête pas la recherche sur les cellules souches
et si l'on n'arrête pas la recherche sur le génome -
de manière à exprimer différentes fonctions corporelles.
Dans la mesure où l'on apprend comment les poulets développent des ailes
et quel est le code pour la différenciation des cellules,
une des choses que l'on pourra faire
est d'interrompre la différentiation des cellules - ce que fait un cancer -
et une des choses que l'on apprendra à faire
est de reprogrammer des cellules comme les cellules souches
de manière à ce qu'elles se différentient en os, en estomac, en peau, en pancréas.
Vous et vos enfants risquez bien d'observer
des duplicatas de parties du corps d'ici pas longtemps
à des endroits du globe où la recherche n'est pas restreinte.
Comment ça marche? Chacun d'entre vous est 0.1% différent
de son voisin. Mais comme seul 3% du génome code,
cela signifie que la différence est d'un millième de 3%.
De faibles variations dans l'expression et la ponctuation
peuvent produire de grandes différences. Prenez une simple affirmation.
(Une femmes sans son mari n'est rien) ( rires )
OK?
C'est clair. Les hommes lisent cette phrase,
ils la regardent et ils lisent ça.
(Une femme, sans son mari, n'est rien.) OK?
Mais les femmes regardent cette phrase et disent "non, c'est faux."
"Il faut la lire comme ça."
(Une femme : sans elle, l'homme n'est rien.) ( rires )
C'est ce que font vos gènes.
C'est pour ça que vous êtes à 1 pour 1000 différents de cette personne-là .
OK? Il est assez beau mais...
Je ne vais pas en dire plus.
Vous pouvez faire ça même sans changer la ponctuation
Vous pouvez regarder ça. (The IRS = service américain de taxation des impôts)
Ils voient les choses de manière légèrement différente.
Ils observent le même monde et disent...
(les leurs) ( rires )
C'est comme ça que le même code génétique... C'est pour ça que vous avez 30'000 gènes,
les souris en ont 30'000, vos maris en ont 30'000.
Les souris et les hommes sont les même. Les femmes savent ça, mais bref.
Vous pouvez effectuer de faibles variations de code génétique
et obtenir des résultats complètement différents
même en utilisant le même alignement de lettres.
(Allons-y ensemble - Allons la chercher) C'est ce que font vos gènes chaque jour.
C'est pour ça que parfois les gènes d'une personne
n'ont pas à changer grand chose pour produire un cancer.
Ces puces ont la taille d'une carte de crédit.
Elles peuvent rechercher 60'000 maladies génétiques.
ça soulève des questions sur la vie privée, l'assurabilité
et plein d'autres choses mais ça nous permet aussi de rechercher une maladie
parce que si vous analysez une personne leucémique avec l'un de ces appareils,
trois maladies avec des syndromes cliniques
très similaires se révèlent être
des maladies complètement différentes.
Car, pour les leucémies ALL, le set de gènes d'en haut qui est surexprimé.
Pour les MLL, c'est le set de gènes central.
Et pour les AML, c'est le set de gènes qui se trouve en bas.
Et si l'un de ces sets est exprimé dans votre corps,
vous prenez Gleevec et vous est guéri.
Si ce n'est pas exprimé,
si vous n'avez pas l'un de ces types -
un des trois en particulier - ne prenez pas Gleevec.
ça n'aura aucun effet sur vous.
Pareil pour Receptin si vous avez le cancer du sein.
Vous n'avez pas de récepteur HER-2, ne prenez pas Receptin.
ça change toute la médecine. ça change les prédictions de la médecine.
ça change la manière dont la médecine fonctionne.
Quand la plupart d'entre nous était encore au gymnase,
le plus grand recueil de connaissances était ça.
Mais il se trouve que ce n'est plus du tout aussi important que ça.
La Bibliothèque du Congrès Américain, en termes de volume de données imprimées,
contient moins de données que ce qui sort chaque mois
d'une bonne société de génomique sous forme de chimique.
Je répète : Une seule société de génomique
génère plus de données sous forme chimique
que ce qui se trouve dans collections imprimées de la Bibliothèque du Congrès Américain.
C'est ce qui a stimulé l'économie américaine. C'est la loi de Moore.
On sait tous que le prix des ordinateurs diminue de moitié tous les 18 mois,
et que leur puissance double, pas vrai?
Mais quand vous mettez ça côte à côte avec la vitesse
à laquelle les données génétiques sont déposées dans GenBank,
la loi de Moore se retrouve là. C'est la ligne bleue.
C'est une échelle logarithmique et c'est ce qu'une croissance super exponentielle signifie.
ça va forcer les ordinateurs à se développer encore plus vite
qu'il ne l'ont fait parce que jusqu'à présent
aucune application requise ne s'est développée
plus vite que la loi de Moore. Maintenant si.
Voici une carte intéressante.
C'est une carte qui a été élaborée à l'école de commerce de Harvard.
Une question vraiment intéressante est : si toutes ces données sont gratuites,
qui les utilise? C'est la plus grande bibliothèque du monde.
Et bien il se révèle que près de 27millions de millions de bits
se déplacent à l'intérieur des États-Unis mêmes,
environ 4.6 millions de millions de donnés vont en Europe
et 5.5 au Japon. Il n'y a quasiment aucune communication
avec le Japon et personne d'autre ne lit ces données.
C'est gratuit. Personne ne le lit. Ils se concentrent sur la guerre,
ils se concentrent sur Bush, ils ne s'intéressent pas à la vie.
Voilà donc à quoi ressemble le nouveau monde.
C'est le monde génomico-lettré. Et c'est problématique.
En fait, ce n'est pas un monde génomico-lettré.
Vous pouvez diviser ça en États.
Et observer ces états monter et descendre, en fonction
de leur capacité à parler la langue de la vie.
Vous pouvez voir New York tomber de la montagne,
et vous pouvez voir le New Jersey tomber de la montagne,
et vous pouvez observer l'essor de nouveaux empires de l'intelligence.
Et vous pouvez diviser ça en pays parce qu'il ne s'agit que de certains pays.
Et si vous voulez être plus spécifique,
il s'agit en fait de certains codes postaux.
( rires )
Alors, vous voulez savoir ou la vie se développe?
Et bien en Californie du Sud, c'est en 92121. C'est tout.
Et il s'agit d'un triangle formé de Sulk*, Scripps et UCSD.
Et ça s'appelle Torrey Pines Road.
Cela signifie qu'il n'y a pas besoin d'avoir un grand pays pour avoir du succès,
que vous n'avez pas besoin de beaucoup de monde pour avoir du succès.
Et cela signifie que vous pouvez regrouper
la majorité des richesses d'un pays dans 3 ou 4 Boeing 747.
C'est pareil en Massachusetts. C'est un peu plus répandu mais...
ah, d'ailleurs, ceux qui ont la même couleur sont contigus.
Quel est le résultat de tout cela?
Dans une société agraire, la différence
entre le plus riche et le plus démuni,
entre le plus productif et le moins productif, était de 5 contre 1. Pourquoi?
Parce que dans l'agriculture, si vous avez 10 enfants
et que vous vous levez un peu plus tôt et travaillez un peu plus dur,
vous pouviez générer en moyenne environ 5 fois plus
de richesse que votre voisin.
Dans une société intellectuelle, ce rapport est de 427 contre 1.
ça importe énormément si vous êtes lettré, pas seulement si vous pouvez
lire et écrire en Anglais, en Français et en Allemand,
mais aussi en Microsoft, en Linux et en Apple.
Dans peu de temps, ça importera aussi d'être lettré en code de la vie.
Donc si vous devez avoir peur de quelque chose,
c'est de perdre la balle des yeux.
Parce que ça importe vraiment de savoir qui peut parler la langue de la vie.
C'est pour ça que des nations s'essorent et s'effondrent.
Si vous retourner jusque dans les années 1870,
le pays le plus productif sur Terre, par personne, était l'Australie.
Et la Nouvelle-Zélande était tout là-haut. Et les États-Unis sont arrivées à peu près dans les années 1950,
puis la Suisse en 1973 et puis de nouveau les USA en tête de liste...
on a battu leur chocolat et leurs horloges coucou.
Et aujourd'hui, bien sûr, vous savez tous que le pays le plus productif
sur Terre est le Luxembourg qui produit, par personne,
environ un tiers de richesse de plus que les États-Unis.
Un minuscule pays sans accès à la mer. Pas de pétrole. Pas de diamants. Pas de ressources naturelles.
Juste des habitants intelligents qui brassent de l'information. Différentes règles.
Voici différentes capacité de production.
C'est le nombre de personnes nécessaires à la production d'un seul brevet US.
Environ 3'000 Américains, 6'000 Coréens, 14'000 Britishs,
790'000 Argentiniens. Vous voulez savoir pourquoi l'Argentine est en train de plonger?
ça n'a rien à voir avec l'inflation.
Rien à voir avec la privatisation.
Vous pouvez prendre un économiste de la Ivy League de Harvard
et lui donner l'Argentine. L'Argentine ne remonte pas
parce qu'il ne comprend pas comment les règles se sont transformées.
Ah oui, il faut aussi environ 5.6 millions d'Indiens.
Et bien regardez ce qu'il advient de l'Inde.
L'Inde et la Chine représentait 40% de l'économie mondiale
lors de la Révolution Industrielle. Il en représente environ 4.8% à présent.
Deux milliards d'habitants. Un tiers de la population mondiale produit
5% de la richesse parce qu'ils n'ont pas saisi ce changement.
Parce qu'ils continuent à traiter les gens comme des paysans
et non comme les rentiers d'un projet commun.
Ils n'ont pas gardé les gens éduqués.
Ils n'ont pas développé les commerces. Ils n'ont pas partagé leur stocks.
Silicon Valley l'a fait. Et c'est pour ça que l'on dit
que Silicon Valley s'est développée grâce aux IC (Invested Capital = investissements).
Pas les Circuits Intégrés, les Chinois et les Indiens.
( rires )
Voilà ce qui se passe dans le monde.
Il s'avère que si vous vous étiez rendus à l'ONU en 1950,
au moment où elle a été fondée, il y avait 50 pays dans le monde.
Il y en a environ 192 de nos jours.
Les pays se divisent, se séparent, se succèdent et échouent les uns après les autres.
ça se fragmente de plus en plus, ça ne s'arrête pas.
Dans les années 1990, ces pays étaient des pays
qui n'existaient pas avant.
Et ça n'inclut pas les fusions ou les changements de noms ou de drapeau.
Environ 3.12 pays sont générés chaque année.
La population prend le contrôle de leur propre état,
parfois pour le meilleur et parfois pour le pire.
L'aspect vraiment intéressant est que vous et vos enfants
avez le pouvoir de créer de puissants empires
et vous n'avez pas besoin de grand chose pour le faire.
( musique )
Et comme la chanson touche à sa fin, j'allais expliquer
comment utiliser ces données pour produire de grandes quantités d'argent,
et comment ce code fonctionne.
( modérateur : ) Encore deux minutes!
( rires )
Non, je vais m'arrêter là et on continuera l'année prochaine
parce que je ne veux pas empiéter sur la présentation de Laurie.
Merci beaucoup.